Earlier this year,
I was invited by Nick Skidmore,
editor,
a vintage classics at Penguin to write
the forward to the 50th anniversary
edition of the single volume of bridged
version of Alexander's Solzhenitsyn's,
the Gulag archipelago.
This was perhaps the single greatest
honor that has ever be fallen me given
the historical importance of Social
Nixon's book as well as its great
personal impact on me.
The Gulag archipelago in its full form
was a three volume text,
originally written between 1958 and 1968
at first saw publication in 1973 and was
translated into English a year later.
It describes life in the Soviet forced
labor camp system,
the ghoulag through a narrative compiled
from interviews,
personal statements from inmates,
diaries,
legal and historical documents,
and the author's own experience as a
gulag prisoner following its appearance.
The books circulated underground in the
Soviet Union until its formal
publication in 1989 in the literary
journal Novy Mirror,
which published a third of the work in
three issues since the Soviet Union
dissolved.
The entire book has been published and
has been made mandatory reading in the
Russian school curriculum.
The 50th anniversary edition is slated
for release November first 2018.
Here's a brief biography of the author
Alexander Social Nitsa from the book
social units and was born in 1918 and
grew up in Rostov on dawn.
He graduated in physics and mathematics
from Rostov University and studied
literature by correspondence course at
Moscow university in World War II.
He fought as an artillery officer
attaining the rank of captain in 1945.
However,
after making derogatory remarks about
Stalin in a letter,
he was arrested and summarily sentenced
to eight years in forced labor camps,
followed by internal exile in 1957.
He was formerly rehabilitated and
settled down to teaching and writing.
Here's a description of the book from
the back cover.
The officially approved abridgment of
the Gulag archipelago volumes one,
two,
and three.
A vast canvas of camps,
prisons,
transit centers,
and secret police of informers and spies
and interrogators,
but also of everyday heroism.
The Gulag archipelago is Alexander
Solzhenitsyn as grand master work.
Based on the testimony of some 200
survivors and on the recollection of
soldier units and his own 11 years in
labor camps in exile,
it chronicles the story of those at the
heart of the Soviet Union who opposed
stolen and for whom the key to survival
lay,
not in hope,
but in despair,
a thoroughly research document and a
feet of literary and imaginative power.
This edition of the Gulag archipelago
was a bridged into one volume at the
author's wish and with his full
cooperation,
Doris lessing 19,
19 to 2013,
a British novelist,
playwright,
librettist biographer and short story
writer and winner of the 2007 Nobel
Prize for Literature says of the Gulag
Archipelago.
It helped to bring down an empire.
Its importance can hardly be
exaggerated.
This is Solzhenitsyn's own forward to
the original abridgment.
I dedicate this to all those who did not
live to tell it,
and may they please forgive me for not
having seen it all nor remembered at all
for not having defined at all.
If it were possible for any nation to
fathom another people's bitter
experience through a book.
How much easier it's future fate would
become and how many calamities and
mistakes could avoid,
but it is very difficult.
There always is this fallacious belief.
It would not be the same here,
here such things are impossible.
Alas,
all the evil of the 20th century is
possible everywhere on earth.
Yet I have not given up all hope that
human beings in nations may be able in
spite of all to learn from the
experience of other people without
having to live through it personally.
Therefore,
I gratefully accept Professor Erickson
suggestion to create a one volume
abridgement of my three volume work,
the Gulag archipelago in order to
facilitate it's reading for those who do
not have much time in this hectic
century of ours.
I think Professor Erickson for his
generous initiative as well as for the
tactfulness,
the literary taste and the understanding
of western readers,
which he displayed during the work on
the abridgment Edward III Erickson
Junior,
1939 to 2017 who served as the editor of
the Abridge single volume version of the
gulag.
Archipelago was professor emeritus of
English at Calvin College and the author
of many other books,
including the soldier knits and reader.
The apocalyptic vision of Mikhail
Bulgakov is the master and Margarita and
the soul and barbed wire and
introduction to social units,
and this is what he had to say when he
introduced the abridged version
in 1994 after years of forced exile in
the West,
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn returned to
Russia at one town meeting,
held on his Trans Siberian whistle stop
tour to reacquaint himself with his
homeland.
He was confronted by this rebuke.
It is you and your writing that started
it all and brought our country to the
verge of collapse and devastation.
Russia doesn't need you,
so go back to your blessing America
units and instantly replied that to his
dying day,
he would keep fighting against the evil
ideology that was capable of slaying one
third of his country's population.
The meeting erupted in applause.
That sort of exchange was unimaginable
when the president abridgment of the
Gulag archipelago first appeared in
1985.
Almost no one expected then that within
a few years the Soviet Union would
collapse and almost in a day like the
legendary one horse.
Shay.
Yep.
Now the dramatic events that put the
closing punctuation mark on the Soviet
parentheses in Russian history have
also,
we may say,
brought an end to what the great Russian
poet Anna Akhmatova called the true 20th
century.
This for short and century running from
1914 to 1917 to 1989,
1991 was the era when Utopian dreams
rooted in lightened,
meant optimism came to rely on brute
force to make ideological schemes
prevail.
The 20th century is proven in
quantitative terms,
at least the most murderous in human
history.
As governments killed their subjects at
record rates for decades,
the word Holocaust served as shorthand
for modern man's inhumanity demand.
Then one lone man added a second such
term Ghoulag,
which now appears in dictionaries as a
common noun social units,
and was one of the precious few who did
anticipate the demise of the Soviet
experiment and he thought his book would
help.
Oh yes.
Ghoulag was destined to affect the
course of history.
I was sure of that on one of his darkest
days,
February twelfth,
Nineteen,
74 the day before he was forced into
exile and precisely because the Gulag
had appeared in the West.
He mused you Bolsheviks are finished.
There are no two ways about it,
what satisfaction he felt then when some
early reviews such as one from the
Frankfurter Allgemeine,
a leading German newspaper,
caught his intentions.
The time may come when we date the
beginning of the collapse of the Soviet
system from the appearance of ghoulag.
American diplomat and scholar George
Kennan hailed the work as the greatest
and most powerful single indictment of a
political regime ever to be leveled in
modern times.
One sure to stick in the craw of the
Soviet propaganda machine with
increasing discomfort until it is done
its work.
Soldier units and has proven prescient
on other matters as well.
Not only did he reiterated in the teeth
of the prevailing opinion of Western
specialists on Soviet affairs,
that he was absolutely convinced that
communism will go.
He also insisted most resolutely and
against all seeming reason that he
expected to be reunited with his beloved
Russia.
In a strange way,
I not only hope,
I'm inwardly convinced that I shall go
back,
I mean my physical return,
not just my books,
and that contradicts all rationality is
improbable.
Prerequisites were that his citizenship
be restored,
that the charge of treason against him
be dropped and that all of his books be
published in his homeland.
After his prophecies were fulfilled.
A friend of his reminisced,
it seemed crazy to me at the time,
but it was a real conviction,
a poet's knowledge.
He sees the man sees.
However,
historians ultimately apportion the
credit for ending the Cold War soldier
units and Dubai notably played a part in
bringing the Soviet edifice down to
rubble.
His writings de legitimize communism in
his homeland and discredited it abroad.
He was much too modest in depicting
himself as a little calf foolishly
budding a mighty oak and thinking this
could bring it down as David Remnick,
editor of the New Yorker declares in
terms of the effect it has had on
history,
social units,
and is the dominant writer of the
century.
Who Else compares?
Orwell,
Kessler.
Remnick concludes that to some extent
you have to credit the literary works of
Alexander Solzhenitsyn with helping to
bring down the last empire on earth.
So after that introductory material my
forward,
it begins with an excerpt from the
speech delivered by soldier knits into
the Swedish Academy on the occasion of
his acceptance of the Nobel Prize for
literature.
Once we have taken up the word,
it is thereafter impossible to turn
away.
A writer is no detached judge of his
countrymen and contemporaries.
He is an accomplice to all the evil
committed in this country or bias
people,
and if the tanks of his father
fatherland have bloodied the pavement of
a foreign capital,
then rust colored stains have forever be
spattered the writers face,
and if on some fateful night a trusting
friend is strangled in his sleep than
the palms of the writer bear,
the bruises from that rope.
And if his youthful fellow citizens
nonchalantly proclaimed the advantages
of debauchery over humbled toil.
If they abandon themselves to drugs or
sees hostages,
then this stench to his mingled with the
breadth of the writer.
Have we the insulins to declare that we
do not answer for the evils of today's
world.
The simple act of an ordinary,
brave man is not to participate in lies,
not to support false actions.
His rule.
Let that come into the world.
Let it even reign supreme only not
through me,
but it is within the power of writers
and artists to do much more to defeat
the lie for in the struggle with lies.
Art has always triumphed and Shell
always triumph.
Visibly irrefutably for all lies can
prevail against much in this world,
but never against art.
One word of truth shall outweigh the
whole world.
First,
you defend your homeland against the
Nazis serving as a twice decorated
soldier on the eastern front in the
criminally ill prepared Soviet Red Army.
Then you're arrested,
humiliated,
stripped of your military rank,
charged under the hospices of the all
purpose.
Article Fifty eight with the
dissemination of anti Soviet propaganda
and dragged off to Moscow's infamous
Lubyanka prison.
They're through the bars of yourself.
You Watch your beloved country
celebrating it's victory in the Great
Patriotic War.
Then you're sentenced in absentia to
eight years of hard labor,
but you got away easy.
It wasn't so long afterward that people
in your position were awarded a tenor
and then a quarter of a century and fate
isn't finished with you,
yet,
not by any means you develop a deadly
cancer in the camp,
endure the exile,
imposed on you after your imprisonment
ends and passed,
very close to death.
Despite all this,
you hold your head high,
you refuse to turn against man or God,
although you have every reason to do so,
you write instead secretly at night
documenting your terrible experiences.
You craft a personal memoir,
a single day in the labor camps and
miracle of miracles.
The clouds part.
The Sun shines through.
Your book is published and in your own
country.
It meets with unparalleled claim
nationally and internationally,
but the sky darkens,
once again in the sun disappears.
The repression returns.
You become,
once again a nonperson,
the secret police,
the dread KGB sees the manuscript of
your next book.
It sees the light of day nonetheless,
but only in the west.
There your reputation grows beyond the
wildest imaginings the Nobel Committee
itself bestows upon you.
It's highest literary honor.
The Soviet authorities stripped of their
camouflage are enraged.
They ordered the secret police to poison
you.
You pass once again near death,
but you continue to write driven,
solitary,
intolerably inspired your gulag.
Archipelago documents,
the absolute and utter corruption of the
dogmas and doctrines of your state,
your empire,
your leaders and yourself,
and then that is printed to not in your
own country,
but in the west.
Once again from copies also dangerously
hidden and smuggled across the borders
and your great book bursts with
unparalleled and dreadful force into the
still naive and unexpecting literary and
intellectual world.
You're expelled from the Soviet Union,
stripped of your citizenship,
forced to take residency in a society,
both strange to you and resistant in its
own way to your prophetic words,
but the power of your stories and the
strength of your morals,
demolish any remaining claims to ethical
and philosophical credibility still made
by the defenders of the collectivist
system that gave rise to all that you
witnessed.
Years Pass,
but not so many from the perspective of
history.
Then another miracle,
the Soviet Union collapses.
You return home,
your citizenship is restored.
You write and speak,
and you're reclaimed homeland until
death claims you in 2008 a year later,
the Gulag archipelago is deemed
mandatory.
Reading by those responsible for
establishing the national school
curriculum of your home country,
you're impossible.
Victory is complete.
The three volumes of the Gulag
archipelago,
one continuous extended scream of
outrage are paradoxically brilliant.
Bitter disbelieving and infused with all
are at the strength characterizing the
best among us in the worst of all
situations.
In that monumental text published in
1973,
Alexander Solzhenitsyn conducted an
experiment in literary investigation,
a hybrid of journalism history and
biography,
unlike anything ever written before or
since.
In 1985,
the author bestowed his approval upon
Edward III Erickson junior single volume
abridgement republished here on the 50th
anniversary of the completion of the
full three volume addition and centenary
of the author's birth and sold some $30
million copies in 35 languages between
the pages of Solzhenitsyn's book.
Apart from the documentation of the
horrors of the legions of the dead
counted and uncounted and the masses
whose lives were torn asunder are the
innumerable soul chilling personal
stories carefully preserved,
making the tragedy of mass,
betrayal,
torture,
and death.
Not The mere statistic stolen,
so disdainfully described,
but individual real and terrible.
It is a matter of pure historical fact
that the Gulag archipelago played a
primary role in bringing the Soviet
Empire to its knees.
Although economically unsustainable,
ruled in the most corrupt manner
imaginable and reliant on the slavery
and enforced deceit of its citizens.
The Soviet system managed to stumble
forward through far too many decades
before being cut to the quick,
the courageous leaders of the labor
unions in Poland,
the great Pope John Paul two and the
American president,
Ronald Reagan,
with his blunt insistence that the West
faced an evil empire all played their
role in its defeat and collapse.
It was Solzhenitsyn,
however,
who's revelations made it positively
shameful to defend not just the Soviet
state,
but the very system of thought that made
that state what it was,
it was soldier units new.
Most crucially made the case that the
terrible excesses of communism could not
be conveniently blamed on the corruption
of the Soviet leadership,
the cult of personality surrounding
stolen or the failure to put the
otherwise stellar and admirable utopian
principles of Marxism into proper
practice.
It was Solzhenitsyn who demonstrated
that the death of millions and the
devastation of many more were instead a
direct causal consequence of the
philosophy.
Worse,
perhaps the theology driving the
communist system,
the hypothetically egalitarian
universalist doctrines of Karl Marx
contained,
hidden within them,
sufficient hatred,
resentment,
envy,
and denial of culpability and
responsibility to produce nothing but
poison and death when manifested in the
world.
For Mark's man was a member of a class,
an economic class,
a group that and little more and
history,
nothing but the battleground of classes
and groups is admires,
regarded,
continue to regard marks doctrine as one
of compassion,
moral by definition,
virtuous by fit.
Consider the working classes in all
their oppression and work forthrightly
to free them,
but hate may well be a stronger and more
compelling motivator than love.
In consequence,
it took no time in the aftermath of the
Russian revolution.
For Solidarity with the common man and
the apparently laudable demand for
universal quality to manifest it's
unarticulated and ever darkening,
shadow
first came the most brutal indictment of
the class enemy then came the ever
expanding definition of that enemy until
every single person in the entirety of
the State found him or herself at risk
of encapsulation within that insatiable
and devouring net,
the verdict delivered to those deemed at
fault by those who elevated themselves
to this simultaneously held positions of
judge,
jury and executioner,
the necessity to eradicate the
victimizers,
the oppressors in toto without any
consideration whatsoever for reactionary
niceties such as individual innocence.
Let us note as well this outcome wasn't
the result of the initially pristine
Marxist doctrine becoming corrupted over
time,
but something apparent and present at
the very beginning of the Soviet state
itself.
Sojourn,
it's insights.
For example,
one,
Martin lapsis writing for the newspaper
read terror November first 1918.
We are not fighting against single
individuals.
We are exterminating the bourgeoisie as
a class.
It is not necessary during the
interrogation to look for evidence
proving that the accused opposed the
Soviets by word or action.
The first question you should ask him
is,
what class does he belong to?
What is his origin,
his education,
and his profession?
These are the questions that will
determine the fate of the accused such
as the sense an essence of red terror.
It is necessary to think when you read
such a thing to meditate long and hard
on the message,
it is necessary to recognize,
for example,
that the writer believed that it would
be better to execute 10,000
potentially innocent individuals than to
allow one poisonous member of the
oppressor class to remain free is
equally necessary.
To pose the question who precisely
belonged to that hypothetical entity,
the bourgeoisie.
It is not as if the boundaries of such a
category or self evident there for the
mere perceiving they must be drawn,
but where exactly and more importantly
by whom or by what if it's hate
inscribing the lines instead of love,
they will inevitably be drawn so that
the lowest,
meanest,
most cruel and useless of the conceptual
geographers will be justified in
manifesting the greatest possible evil
and producing the greatest possible
misery members of the Swazi beyond all
redemption.
They had to go as a matter of course,
one of their wives,
children,
even their grandchildren,
off with their heads to all were
encouraged to be corrupted by their
class identity and their destruction.
Therefore ethically necessitated.
How convenient that the darkest and
diarist of all possible motivations
could be granted,
the highest of moral standings that was
a true marriage of Hell and heaven.
What values?
What philosophical presumptions,
truly dominated under such circumstances
was it desire for brotherhood,
dignity and freedom from want?
Not In the least,
not given the outcome.
It was instead and obviously the
murderous rage of hundreds of thousands
of biblical canes each looking to
torture,
destroy,
and sacrifice their own private ables.
There is simply no other manner of
accounting for the corpses.
What can be concluded in the deepest,
most permanent sense from Solzhenitsyn's
anguished,
ghoulag narrative.
First,
we learn what is indisputable,
what we all should have learned by now,
what we have nonetheless failed to learn
that the left like the right can go too
far,
that the left has in the past,
gone much too far.
Second,
we learn what is far more subtle and
difficult.
How and why that going too far occurs.
We learn as social units and so
profoundly insists that the line
dividing good and evil cuts through the
heart of every human being,
and we learned as well that we all are
each of us,
Cymbalta,
caneously,
oppressor and oppressed.
Thus,
we come to realize that the twin
categories of or presser and justice
seeking victim can be made endlessly
inclusive.
This is not least because we all benefit
unfairly and are all equally victimized
by our thrownness are arbitrary
placement in the flow of time.
We all accrue undeserved and somewhat
random privileged from the vagaries of
our place of birth or inequitably,
distributed talents,
our ethnicity,
race,
culture,
and sex.
We all belong to a group,
some group that has been elevated and
comparative status through no effort of
our own.
This is true in some manner along some
dimension of group category for every
solitary individual except for the
single most lowly of all at some time
and in some manner we may all in
consequence be justly targeted as
oppressors and may all equally seek
justice or revenge as victims even if
the initiators of the revolution had
therefore in their most pure moments
being driven by a holy desire to lift up
the downtrodden,
was it not guaranteed that they would be
overtaken by those motivated primarily
by envy,
hate and the desire to destroy.
As the revolution progressed,
hence the establishment of the hungrily
growing and most often fatal list of
class enemies right from the very first
moments of the communist revolution.
The demolition was aimed first at the
students,
the religious believers and the
socialists continuing under Stalin with
the old revolutionaries themselves and
was followed.
Soon thereafter,
by the annihilation of the successful
peasant farmer Kulaks
and this appetite for destruction wasn't
of the type to be satiated with the
bodies of the perpetrators themselves as
social needs and rights,
they burned out hold nests whole
families from the start and they watched
jealously to be sure that none of the
children,
14,
10,
even six years old,
God away to the last scrapings all had
to go down the same road to the same
common destruction.
This was driven by the perceived even
self perceived guilt of all how else was
it possible for the hundreds of
thousands or perhaps even millions of
informants,
prosecutors,
betrayers and unforgivably,
mute observers to praying and
unforgivably mute observers to spring so
rapidly into being in the tumult of the
red terror.
Thus the doctrine of group identity
inevitably ends with everyone identified
as a class enemy,
an oppressor with everyone unpleasantly
contaminated by bridgewater.
Privilege unfairly enjoying the benefits
be queen by the vagaries of history with
everyone prosecuted without respite for
that corruption and injustice,
no mercy for the oppressor and no
punishment.
Too severe for the crime of
exploitation.
Expiation becomes impossible because
there is no individual guilt,
no individual responsibility,
and therefore no manner in which the
crime of arbitrary birth can be
individually accounted for and all the
misery that can be generated as a
consequence of such an accusation is the
true reason for the accusation.
When everyone is guilty,
all that serves justice is the
punishment of everyone.
When the guilt extends to the existence
of the world's misery itself,
only the fatal punishment will suffice.
It is much more preferable instead and
much more likely to preserve us all from
metastasizing hell's to state
forthrightly.
I am indeed throwing arbitrarily into
history.
I therefore choose to voluntarily
shoulder the responsibility of my
advantages and the burden of my
disadvantages.
Like every other individual,
I am morally bound to pay for my
advantages with my responsibility.
All right,
morally bound to accept my disadvantages
as the price I pay for being.
I will therefore strive not to descend
into bitterness and then seek vengeance
because I have less to my credit and a
greater burden to stumble forward with
than others.
Is this not an a or even the essential
point of difference between the West for
all its faults and the brutal,
terrible egalitarian systems generated
by the pathological communist doctrine?
The great and good framers of the
American republic were,
for example,
anything but utopian.
They took full stock and full measure of
ineradicable human imperfection.
They held modest goals derived not least
from the profoundly cautious common law
tradition of England.
They endeavored to establish a system
the corrupt and ignorant fools we all
are,
could not damage to fatally.
That's humility,
that's clear headed knowledge of the
limitations of human machination and
good intention,
but the communists,
the revolutionaries,
they aimed grandly and admirably,
at least in theory at a more heavenly
vision,
and they began their pursuit with a
hypothetically straightforward and oh,
so morally justifiable enforcement of
economic equality.
Wealth,
however,
was not so easily generated.
The poor could not simply become rich,
but the riches of those who had anything
more than the greatest popper,
no matter how pitiful that more was,
that could be redistributed or at least
destroyed.
That's equality to that sacrifice in the
name of heaven on earth and
redistribution was not enough.
With all its theft,
betrayal,
and death.
Mere economic engineering was
insufficient.
What emerged as well was the overarching
and truly totalitarian desire to remake
man and woman.
As such,
the longing to restructure the human
spirit in the very image of the
communist preconceptions,
attributing to themselves this divine
ability,
this transcendent wisdom,
and with unshakeable belief in the
glowing but ever receiving future.
The newly minted Soviets tortured
thieved,
imprisoned,
lied and betrayed all the wild masking
their great evil with virtue,
it was Solzhenitsyn,
the Gulag archipelago that tore off the
mask and exposed the feral cowardice,
envy,
deceit,
resentment,
and hatred for the individual and for
existence itself.
That pulse beneath others had made the
attempt.
Malcolm Muggeridge reported on the
horrors of d Kula Ization,
the forced collectivization of the all
too recently successful peasantry of the
Ukraine and elsewhere that proceeded the
horrifying famines of the 19 thirties in
the same decade and in the following
years.
George orwell risked his ideological
commitments and his reputation to tell
us all what was truly occurring in the
Soviet Union in the name of
egalitarianism and brotherhood,
but it was Solzhenitsyn who truly shamed
the radical leftists,
forcing them under ground where they
have festered and plotted for the last
40 years,
failing unforgivably to have learned
what all reasonable people should have
learned from the cataclysm of the 20th
century and it's Egalitarian,
utopianism,
and today,
despite everything and under their sway,
almost three decades since the fall of
the Berlin Wall and the apparent
collapse of communism.
We're doing everything we can to forget
what Solzhenitsyn so clearly
demonstrated to our great and richly
deserved peril.
Why don't all our children read the
Gulag archipelago in our high schools as
they now do in Russia?
Why don't our teachers feel compelled to
read the book aloud?
Did we not win the Cold War?
Where the body's not piled high enough,
how high then would be enough?
Why,
for example,
is it still acceptable end in polite
company to profess the philosophy of a
communist or if not that to at least
admire the work of Marx.
Why is it still acceptable to regard the
Marxist doctrine as essentially accurate
in its diagnosis of the hypothetical
evils of the free market democratic
west,
to still consider that doctrine
progressive and fit for the
Compassionate and proper thinking person
$25 million dead through internal
repression in the Soviet Union.
According to the black book of
communism,
$60 million dead in Mao's,
China and an all too likely return to
audit craddick oppression in that
country in the near future.
The horrors of Cambodian killing fields
with their 2 million corpses,
the barely animate body politic of Cuba
where people struggle even now to feed
themselves Venezuela where it is now
been made illegal to attribute a child's
death in hospital to starvation.
No political experiment has ever been
tried so widely with so many disparate
people in so many different countries
with such different histories and failed
so absolutely and catastrophic.
Lee,
is it mere ignorance?
I'll be at of the most inexcusable kind
that allows today's Marxists to flaunt
their continued allegiance to present it
as compassion and care,
or is it instead envy of the successful
in near infinite proportions or
something akin to hatred for mankind
itself?
How much proof do we need?
Why do we still avert our eyes from the
truth?
Perhaps we simply locked sophistication.
Perhaps we just can't understand.
Perhaps our tendency toward compassion
is so powerfully necessary in the
intimacy of our families and friendships
that we cannot contemplate its
limitations.
It's an ability to scale and its
propensity to mutate into hatred of the
oppressor rather than an allegiance with
the oppressed.
Perhaps we cannot comprehend the
limitations and dangers of the Utopian
vision given our definite need to
contemplate and to strive for a better
tomorrow.
We certainly don't seem to imagine,
for example,
that the hypothesis of some state of
future perfection,
for example,
the truly egalitarian and permanent
brotherhood of man can be used to
justify any and all sacrifices
whatsoever.
The pristine and heavenly end,
making all conceivable means no one only
acceptable but morally required.
There are simply no price too great to
pay in pursuit of the ultimate utopia,
and this is particularly true if it is
someone else who foots the bill and it
is clearly the case that we require a
future toward which to orient ourselves
to provide meaning in our life
psychologically speaking.
It is for that reason.
We see the same need expressed
collectively on a much larger scale in
the Judeo Christian vision of the
Promised Land and the Kingdom of Heaven
on earth,
and it is also clearly the case.
That sacrifice is necessary to bring
that desire to instate into being.
That's the discovery of the future
itself,
the necessity to forego instantaneous
gratification in the present,
to delay,
to bargain with fate so the future can
be better twinned with the necessity to
let go,
to burn off,
to separate wheat from chaff and to
sacrifice what is presently unworthy so
that tomorrow can be better than today,
but limits need to be placed around who
or what is deemed dispensable.
And it is exactly the necessity for
interminable sacrifice that constitutes
the terrible counterpart of the Utopian
vision.
Heaven is worth any price,
but who pays Christianity solve that
problem by insisting on the sacrifice of
the self,
insisting that the suffering and
malevolence of the world is the
responsibility of each individual
insisting that each of us sacrifice what
is unworthy and unnecessary and
resentful and deadly and our characters
despite the pain of such sacrifice so
that we can stumble properly uphill
under our respective and voluntarily
shouldered existential burdens,
but it was an is the opinion of the
materialist utopians that someone else
be sacrificed so that heaven itself
might be attained,
some perpetrator or victimizer,
oral oppressor or member of a privileged
group.
A cynic might be forgiven in consequence
for asking,
is it the city of God that is in fact
the aim or is the true aim?
The desire to make a burning sacrificial
pyre of everyone and everything and the
hypothesis of the coming brotherhood of
man.
Merely the cover story,
the camouflage perhaps it is precisely
the horror that is the point and not the
utopia.
It is far from obvious in such
situations.
Just what his horse and what his cart it
is precisely in the aftermath of the
death of 100 million people or more that
such dark questions must be asked and we
should also note that the Utopian vision
dressed as it is inevitably in
compassion,
is a temptation,
particularly difficult to resist and
bay.
Therefore offer a particularly subtle
and insidious justification for mayhem.
Here's some thoughts.
Know some facts.
Every social system produces inequality
at present and every social system has
done so since the beginning of time.
The poor have been with us and will be
with us always and now let's just have
the content of individual.
Paleolithic grave sites provides
evidence for the existence of
substantive variance in the distribution
of ability,
privilege,
and wealth.
Even in our distant past.
The more illustrious of our ancestors
were buried with great possessions,
hordes of precious metals,
weaponry,
jewelry,
and costuming.
The majority,
however,
struggled through their lives and were
buried with nothing.
Inequality is the iron rule,
even among animals with their intense
competition,
for quality living,
space and reproductive opportunity,
even among plants and cities.
Even among the stellar lights,
the doc,
the cosmos themselves were a minority of
privileged and oppressive heavenly
bodies contained in the mass and
thousands,
millions or even billions of average
dispossessed planets.
Inequality is the deepest of problems
built into the structure of reality
itself and will not be solved by the
presumptuous ibiology inspired retooling
of the rare free,
stable and productive democracies of the
world.
The only systems that have produced some
modicum of wealth along with the
inevitable inequality and it's
intendance along with the inevitable
inequality and its attendant suffering,
the only systems that have produced some
modicum of wealth along with the
inevitable inequality and its attendant
suffering or those that evolved in the
west with their roots in the Judeo
Christian tradition.
Precisely those systems that emphasize
above all the essential dignity,
divinity,
and ultimate responsibility of the
individual.
In consequence,
any attempt to attribute the existence
of inequality to the functioning of the
productive institutions.
We have managed to create and protect so
recently in what is still accurately
regarded as the free world will hurt
those who are weakest and most
vulnerable.
First,
the radicals who conflate the activities
of the west with the oppression of the
downtrodden,
therefore do nothing to aid those whom
they purport to prize and plenty to harm
them.
The claims they make to act under the
inspiration of pure compassion must
therefore come to be regarded with the
deepest suspicion,
not least by those who dare to make such
claims themselves.
The dangers of the Utopian vision had
been laid bare even if the reasons those
dangers exist have not yet been fully
unacceptably articulated.
If there was any excuse to be a marxist
in 1917 and both Dostoevsky and nichier
prophesied well before then that there
would be held to pay for that doctrine.
There is absolutely and finally no
excuse now and we know that mostly
because of Alexander Solzhenitsyn and
the Gulag archipelago.
Thank heaven for that great authors,
outrage,
courage and unquenchable thirst for
justice and truth.
It was Solzhenitsyn who warned us that
the catastrophes of the Soviet state
were inextricably and causally linked to
the deceitful blandishments of the
Marxist Utopian Vision.
It was Solzhenitsyn who carefully
documented the price paid in suffering
for the dreadful communist experiment.
And who distilled from that suffering
the wisdom we must all he'd so that such
catastrophe does not visit us again.
Perhaps we could take from his writing
the humility that would allow us to
understand that our mere good intentions
are not sufficient to make us good men
and women.
Perhaps we could take from his writing
the humility that would allow us to
understand that our mere good intentions
are not sufficient to make us good men
and women.
Perhaps we could come to understand that
such intentions are instead all too
often,
the consequence of our unpardonable
historical ignorance are author,
willful blindness and are voracious
hidden appetite for vengeance,
terror and destruction.
Perhaps we could come to remember and to
learn from the intolerable trials
endeared by all those who pass through
the fiery chambers of the Marxists
collectivists ideology.
Perhaps we could derive from that
remembering and learning the wisdom
necessary to take personal
responsibility for the suffering and
malevolence that still so terribly and
unforgivably characterizes the world.
We have been provided with the means to
transform ourselves in due humility by
the literary and moral genius of this
great Russian author.
We should also pray most devoutly to
whatever dad he guides us implicitly or
explicitly for the desire and the will
to learn from what we have been offered.
May God himself eternally fail to
forgive us if in the painstakingly
revealed aftermath of such bloodshed,
torture,
and anguish,
we remain stiff,
necked in cautious and unchanged.